for each of you coming into this did you
have something that you circled as a
priority
uh or maybe a
contrary something you circled that you
really had to keep an eye on something
you were concerned about
just to keep the integrity of the book
you mean yeah i mean for me i just
wanted it to feel like what it felt like
when i read it for the first time and i
mean that was kind of the goal with
everything that we did i think for wic
as well
yeah i mean we actually had a very real
responsibility to john green the author
when elizabeth gabler and i chased it he
had had a couple of bad experiences in
hollywood i mean first of all he didn't
think this book would become a movie he
was just like no one's going to make a
movie about two kids with cancer
and so when we read the book and i fell
in love with it and called elizabeth and
said we have to do this this is just an
extraordinary love story
he would happen to be coming to town so
we went and met him backstage and the
first thing we said was that you know
we're going to make an unsentimental you
know representation of your book you
know we we promise you that the
character will have cannula then who
knows the entire movie and that gus will
walk on one leg like we're not going to
hollywoodize it in any way um
and i think that's a natural thing that
happens a lot of times with books as you
start adapting them you sometimes stray
a little bit away from the source
material and then you stray a little
further and then you stray a little
farther and all of a sudden you're
looking at your script and it doesn't
represent what you fell in love with in
the book um so it was really important
to us to to kind of pay honor to gus and
hazel and and really stick as closely to
it as possible yeah i mean we would even
the actors and me and kind of everybody
the night before we shot a scene we'd go
back and look at the book and read the
chapters again and all that just to
make sure it felt right well we'll
credit um scott and mike our
screenwriters for for a really brilliant
adaptation i mean one of the things
about the book is it's very much hazel's
book it's internal you know a lot of the
the great insights and humor of the book
is sort of in her head the one thing
they did immediately was give gus a
story and really give him a sort of full
a full life
outside of her and then i think that you
know they found ways to work in some of
that great internal dialogue with some
of the voice over stuff but they also
condensed the third act which and john
even admits this was incredibly
sprawling and you know attenuated so um
first thing is they they
turned the book into a great cinematic
experience
it's a hell of a mixtape too
i have to say
the music seemed like that must been a
lot of fun yeah definitely i mean music
is a big part of my process whether i'm
writing or making a movie or whatever
when i went to fox to pitch to try to
get the job i brought them a usb stick
filled with
music just to give them an idea tonally
of what i was thinking and i find that
music is probably the most effective way
to communicate tone to actors or to the
studio or whomever
it's a lot easier to
to play somebody a song than
intellectualize what they need to do on
the day
they just if they feel it and you're in
the same
ballpark tonally it's like everybody's
making the same movie well you also
worked at a record shop
i did
i mean one of the things that josh said
to us when he came in was you know he he
had just lost an incredible mentor of
his to to cancer
the guy that owned the record shop that
gave him his first job so
that was incredibly moving to us when
you told that story and and i think
that emotion carried through in your
directing of it yeah i mean the the song
that you heard at the end playing over
the letter being read is the song i
actually listened to driving back and
forth from the hospital when i went to
see him uh
right before i made my first movie he
passed away and i still
wish that he was around just to see all
i mean he was such a big supporter of
mine and was so kind to me and uh
believed in me and that he never got to
see it uh
any of this stuff come to life is still
real pretty sad
i looked at a lot of uh cameron crows
one of my favorite directors his early
film say anything almost famous jerry
maguire
maguire is one we looked at a lot
especially for the opening montage uh
just the way it moved and the way it
felt and the way it used music uh was an
inspiration uh also for me like terms of
endearment was a movie and when i was
growing up was you know it balanced
humor with with emotion very well and i
felt like the book when i had read it
had that balance shailene wanted to do
it immediately like she was on set with
scott and mike when they were doing
spectacular now and and she was like i
want to do i want to do it we decided
early on that we were going to audition
the role we weren't going to offer it to
anyone who ever wanted to play hazel is
going to have to come in and really sort
of present their take on her um and josh
you think you're initially a little
resistant
she wanted it so bad that i didn't want
her to be in it but also she's she's
such a strong person and she's so i mean
she's so athletic and tall and like 21 i
mean i just was worried
that it wasn't gonna be right but uh
sh we did we mean we auditioned we must
have read 200 people and uh she was the
very first person who spoke and like it
sounded exactly like the voice that i
heard in my head when i read the book
and i was just like well i guess this is
what we're doing i mean her audition was
phenomenal and i will i mean i will say
for me well i've seen it a million times
now and and
i'm
taken away by her performance every time
i mean there she just is incapable
of an inauthentic moment not not only in
the scenes but like in every take
she she's just i think luminous and
really fantastic i remember looking over
my casting director she was doing the
eulogy scene that's what she came in and
auditioned and like we were just both
crying and i was just like why did i
make this so hard on myself i should
have just hired her right when she said
she wanted to do it
but uh but i mean they really gave her
ownership over that role to come in an
audition because it's like once she came
in and nailed that it's like it was hers
i mean that was her i mean there was
never a question again
and then with ansel you know who was
newer you know we once we had shailene
we brought in a bunch of different guys
that we had liked and just did some
chemistry reads and he was really the
first one to totally break her down like
in many many of the guys would come in
and she just dominated them and he came
in and somehow made her feel a little
off balance and insecure and girlish in
a way that nobody else didn't help that
he's six five so he also kind of towered
helped us visually with my problems
which was her size and her strength it's
like he felt
visually just a lot bigger than her
which i think helped sell
the characters you know yeah
and then uh you know one last thing
you mentioned the the amazing effect
that um
well the amazing amazing passion that
people have for the book and what it's
meant to people
uh this experience uh is only a weekend
long so far but
what's it like to be kind of plugged
into all of that and the expectations
that come with it and and and
the upsides it has extraordinary fans
and they love this book i mean they've
read it over and over again so i think
we were all very conscious of trying to
make a movie that that was going to
satisfy them um i think we're very
relieved and happy that it seems to have
not only satisfied them but but you know
it
it's something that i was i think we
were all surprised that you could sell a
movie you know about two kids falling in
love who are both dying of cancer that
people would come out the opening week
and we thought it would be a movie that
people would have to discover outside of
you know the the core fans but um
but look you definitely i mean you can
you can really face plant on this kind
of project um and and
testament to josh i mean he did an
extraordinary job directly it was it was
everybody but uh i mean never in my
wildest dreams that i think this would
do the business that it's done ever like
i thought we were making like a little
indie movie for studio
so it's just been uh
incredible experience uh i can't even
begin to describe it it's been very
surreal